good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now we'll have the
very latest as the uk
sends two royal navy ships to jersey as
a fishing round with france
ramps up plus pencils at the ready were
off to the polling booth in the largest
test of public opinion
outside of a general election also this
morning
looking after your maternal mental
health we'll talk to the tv presenter
ashley james
who's campaigning to raise awareness of
the struggles of becoming a mum
that's at ten to nine this morning and
the augmented art gallery of the future
at halftime we'll talk to the actor and
presenter stephen mangan
about the launch of an interactive art
trail in london's
west end it's thursday may
the 6th troubled waters two royal navy
patrol vessels are sent to jersey after
france
threatens to blockade the island's main
port in a row over fishing rights
super thursday millions set to cast
their ballots for the biggest set of uk
elections outside
a general election in almost 50 years
the battle against coronavirus new
research and israel which suggests
vaccinations
rather than lockdowns are the key to
reducing infections
meanwhile there's no quick fix a warning
that long covered clinics will
need to be around for much longer than
the current funding allows
with thousands already being treated
fueling a backlash calls for a boycott
of the london science museum's climate
exhibition
sponsored by the oil giant shell
and it's becoming wet and windy this
weekend but milder conditions are
on the way until then it's looking cool
and showery once again for today i'll
have the details for you later in the
programme
well a very good morning to you the uk
is sending two royal navy ships to
jersey
as a precaution after france threatened
to blockade the main port and cut power
to the island
over a post-brexit fishing route the
prime minister has said any blockade
would be
completely unjustified as reports
suggest up to 100 french fishing boats
were preparing to sail to the island
later today
to demonstrate against jersey's issuing
of fishing licenses
elena vasilinovic reports
the feud between the uk and france over
fishing rights escalated
after french fishermen threatened to
blockade jersey's main port
in response two royal navy ships were
ordered to waters off the island
on wednesday night the pm spoke to
jersey's chief minister
and the minister for external relations
and in a statement downing street said
the prime minister underlined his
unwavering support for jersey
he said that any blockade would be
completely unjustified
as a precautionary measure the uk will
be sending two
offshore patrol vessels to monitor the
situation
france accuses jersey of imposing extra
conditions on phishing licenses
which it claims is in breach of the
brexit agreement
but jersey authorities say that some
french vessels simply didn't have the
correct documents to get their permits
we believe that the licenses we've
issued
are respectful of the brexit agreement
the question is whether those french
vessels
have provided the full amount of
evidence that they need to
to respect their historic rights in some
of those boots it's now
become apparent that they've not
provided all of that evidence and
we are absolutely prepared
to give those vessels extra time to
provide that evidence
on tuesday the french maritime minister
threatened to cut electricity supply to
jersey
which gets nearly all its power from
france but ireland authorities say
that's likely an empty threat
because they have a commercial contract
with an energy company
and could fire up the island's own power
station
but this row continues to brew and it
seems that neither side is willing to
back down
yet milana vassalinovic sky news
well let's talk to our political
correspondent rob powell i mean this is
certainly heating up rob
yeah i mean it's not unusual necessarily
for all navy vessels to be involved in
fishing protection they've done that for
a very long time
jersey is a crown dependency obviously
the uk has some defense foreign policy
obligations towards it but of course
it's the context that makes this um
interesting the context of brexit and
the context of those threats
uh from france you can see there a
maritime tracker map
which shows french vessels that left
overnight from the normandy coast
that are arriving in saint helia the
main port in jersey
right now i think the little flashing
dot off the coast
of jersey you can see that is hms7 that
arrived in the early hours of this
morning
hms tamar as well is due to arrive in
jersey
uh but doesn't seem to have arrived
there uh yet
now why this has all happened now is
because there had been
a kind of buffer period an interim
period where
where friendships were allowed access to
jersey waters as they had done
when we were within the eu that ran out
on friday and a new
licensing regime came in
40 or so french ships were given
licenses to fish 17 or so
haven't yet had those licenses granted
the french say that they're being asked
for information
that is unnecessary the jersey
authorities say
that they simply haven't provided the
necessary data yet
i think the french are also unhappy
about what they see as new restrictions
being put on them
um over and above where they were able
to fish before
so while this is new actually it comes
against a backdrop of tension
you had jersey fishermen blockading that
very same port
back in march protesting over how they
were being treated by the french so i
think
uh maybe more indication that those two
thorny issues during the brexit
negotiations
of fishing and of northern ireland from
what we've seen in the last few months
they haven't just vanished because we've
left the eu
okay rob thank you now millions of
britons are casting their votes today
for the largest set of elections outside
of a general election in 50 years
the scottish and welsh people voting in
their parliamentary elections which
happen every five years
and voted in england setting their
sights on the mayoral contest
and the hartley pool parliamentary
by-election here's our economics and
data editor
ed conway with more now this may not be
a general election but these polls and
the results could prove incredibly
important
across much of britain but before we get
to that let's take a moment to consider
what's going on and the short answer is
quite a lot actually there are depending
on how you count it actually seven
or eight separate things happening here
so first of all
you've got the scottish and welsh
parliament elections they happen every
five years there's the english council
elections the local elections in this
case there's actually two years worth of
them bundled into one because last
year's cancelled
due to covert you've got the london
assembly elections and the vote for the
london
mayor those were also postponed and
you've got another 12 elected mayors
across various metropolitan and regional
areas
of england you've got police and crime
commissioner elections too and as if
that weren't
all enough you've also got a
parliamentary by-election to elect a new
mp
for hartlepool to make it more
complicated i'm afraid
many of these different elections
involve slightly different voting
systems so
hartlepool that's simple as with general
elections the candidate with the most
votes
wins but the scottish and welsh
elections they involve something called
the additional
member system you vote once for a
candidate in your local constituency and
a second time
for a party those second votes go
towards a regional list
of members of these parliaments it's a
form of proportional representation the
idea being to ensure that smaller
parties get represented in the
parliaments and it makes
getting a majority very difficult indeed
though not impossible
the additional member system that's also
used for the london assembly election
but
not for the london mayor that election
uses a different voting system the
supplementary vote where you choose
a first and a second choice candidate
it's not proportional it's not
proportional representation
but it's designed to find a candidate
who most people either want or kind of
want
same system supplementary vote for the
directly elected mayors elsewhere around
the uk and the police and crime
commissioners
too you get the idea seven or eight
elections
three different voting systems three
days maybe more
of counting as we start to piece
together the latest picture
of politics around great britain
well don't forget we'll bring you all
the results live right here on sky news
starting with a special programme
from midnight tonight through into
friday and we'll bring you the results
of the hartlepool by-election and all
the others as they come in
with full coverage continuing here on
breakfast tomorrow
now a new study from israel has shown
that two doses of the fisa
vaccine can provide more than 95
protection against infection severe
illness and death from coving 19.
new cases have dropped dramatically
since the country's vaccination program
began from a peak of more than about 10
000 a day in january to a few hundred in
march
when lockdown was eventually lifted
well let's get the latest amanda brady
who's in the newsroom i mean these
certainly
a very positive result sender
there they are stephen a very
significant study this is the
first kind of real detail we've had from
the israeli vaccination program it's
from their ministry of health
it's published in the lancet today and i
think scientists all over the world will
be looking at this because
israel has used exclusively the pfizer
biontech
vaccine and it was supplied on the
understanding that data
from the israeli vaccination program
would be published to demonstrate
efficacy of that particular vaccine what
it shows us
is that two dolces gives 95
protection against infection severe
illness and death a single job
58 protection against infection 76
protection against hospital admission
and 77
protection against death and israel
currently leading the world with
56 of its population fully vaccinated
against culvert 19.
now in january of this year they were
still in lockdown
there they were reporting 10 000 cases a
day
but they came out of lockdown in march
and that number had dropped down to just
a few hundred cases per day so israel
really showing the world how a
vaccination program can be implemented
and we're seeing now the benefits of how
they have done it
and just ultimately a road map
out of covert experts saying that this
study really shows
the vaccines work and ultimately
will be the path to dealing with the
pandemic and and
basically getting it over and done with
okay ender thank you
well let's have a look at the latest
coveted figures for the uk they've been
2144 new cases
of coronavirus in the last 24 hours 27
more deaths have been reported
which means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test is now
127 and 570.
a hundred and twenty seven thousand one
hundred and seventy people have had
their first vaccination
two hundred and fifty seven thousand
four hundred and eighty six have had
their second
so more than fifty million injections in
total
have been given out across the uk
well let's uh get a sort of overview of
the international picture with margaret
harris from the world health
organization who joins us now it's good
to see you this morning
look first and foremost can i get your
reaction to what we've now
seen in this sort of further study
coming out of israel it's really
positive news
indeed good morning stephen it is
positive news and what's really
important
about that is the provision of that data
so every country that's vaccinating uh
if they collect that data we understand
much
more about what the vaccines are doing
and and how we can use them most
effectively the united kingdom is doing
the same thing
we're getting some very interesting and
very important informative studies out
of the united kingdom as well
meanwhile we're getting information
about the first sort of
tweaked vaccine to deal with with some
of the more concerning variants i think
that's a moderna vaccine that's been
tweaked i mean clearly
this in itself is an important step
forward isn't it as we
as we try to deal with this moving
forward
it's a very important step but the
critical step is bringing down the
transmission worldwide i think you might
remember my director general saying just
a couple of days ago that in the last
couple of weeks
we've seen the same number of cases as
we saw in the first
five months of the pandemic so it took
five months
to reach the number of new infections
we're now seeing every
every week so we're in the most intense
phase even though
countries like that in the united
kingdom may not be feeling that right
now because you've done such a great job
with vaccination
and also with the public health and
social measures to get your numbers down
um but we are actually in a really
critical phase so the most important
thing we can do
to make sure that vaccine can really uh
fulfill its promise to lead us out of
the pandemic
is to get the numbers down so that we're
not constantly playing catch up with
variants
so how do we do that then in terms of
the international
response to all of this because we need
to start viewing it more as a
global issue don't we but i mean there's
all this pressure to start sending
sort of vaccines everywhere i mean
presumably
in some of the countries they haven't
got the infrastructure to deliver the
vaccines
necessarily as effectively as they need
to do but it's a more complicated
picture isn't it you're absolutely right
it's a very complicated picture
but we're seeing some very positive
momentum toward vaccine
sharing and we're also seeing positive
momentum toward
waving patents so that vaccines can
actually be produced
where they're needed on the
infrastructure certainly actually no
country is perfect
but that's our job and we with unicef
work with each country
to ensure they can roll out the vaccines
now sometimes they also lack the funds
to to pay the people to roll them out
on the spot so we're that's why we're
also constantly talking about funding
it is critical that we all help each
other
to make sure that we have the very best
vaccine programs
possible but as i said at the same time
it is also critical
that we really maintain and ensure that
every country is doing the public health
social measures
to bring the transmission down so that
the vaccine programs can be as effective
as possible
can i ask what your assessment of the
situation in india is because i mean
clearly it is dire at the moment clearly
the health system there is
is really struggling to cope but i mean
they are vaccinating
millions and millions of people it is a
problem just as it is
such a huge country
well that's one of the problems but as
as i think we've discussed before
if this if the transmission of this
virus
gets to such intensity that you're
struggling
to stop it you know if it's really got
to the wildfire stage you have too many
people
who are have got the severe form and the
severe form takes
intensive care it takes intensive use of
stuff
it takes it means that your hospital
beds your hospital
staff are just overwhelmed very rapidly
so that's
un sadly horrifically what we're seeing
in india
and again the way to stop it is to
step up your your finding on all the
cases but get
everybody to stop the movement to do the
physical distancing
not to go physically into work if they
if they don't have to
but also support them to be able to stay
at home
because a lot of people may be in
economic circumstances which makes it
impossible for them to simply stay in
place
i mean clearly there is a divide between
those countries
i mean the wealthier countries generally
who are doing well
with this and those other countries that
aren't can i guess what
i mean what is your take on the fact
that here in the uk for example we're
looking at
reopening international travel pretty
soon
but obviously with quite a lot of
caveats and that the traffic light
system and what have you
is is that a safe thing to do at this
time
with those caveats in place or should we
be looking to just stay at home at the
moment
well certainly with travel and anyone i
would i put
include myself think about why you're
traveling and whether you need to at
this point
now we have got very detailed technical
guidance
on how governments can do this and one
of the critical things is what you refer
to
knowing the epidemiology and the place
that you're going to
also the place that you're going to
needs to know your epidemiology
the idea being that you don't want to
seed an
outbreak in another country but you also
don't want to bring it back with you
so it is something that has to be done
with great care with great thought with
excellent planning and make sure you've
got
all the things in place like the ability
to test who's coming through
the ability to follow them through
either end and
if you're traveling if you're thinking
of traveling for letter remember things
can change very quickly we've seen this
in this in this year so don't be upset
if you suddenly find yourself somewhere
and you can't get back or
or provisions change because this is
a rapidly moving outbreak it's
constantly surprising all of us and um
everybody is doing their best and basing
their decisions on evidence but don't
expect that
a decision is always set in stone we
have to go backwards and forwards with
our measures
according to what the virus is doing
margaret good to talk to you
thank you it's a pleasure
now still to come for you this morning
your page
has not been found at half past seven
we'll be talking to
an attorney about facebook's decision to
uphold donald trump's ban
on the social media site now are vacti
vaccines more effective than lockdowns
we'll talk to an expert on infectious
diseases about
this latest covert data from israel
that's at 8 20.
and i'm going to be talking to a doctor
who's helped develop a device that will
allow those who suffer
with motor neurone disease to
communicate
that's at 8 40.
now let's have a look at some of the
other stories making the headlines for
you
this morning and u.s president biden has
backed a proposed temporary waiver
of intellectual property rights for
covid19 vaccines which was put forward
by
the world trade organization and
supported by more than a hundred other
countries
the world health organization called it
a monumental moment
in the fight against kovid 19.
anti-government protests have taken
place in colombia for the eighth
consecutive day
riot police fired tear gas and flash
bangs at protesters
as they marched on bogota's plaza
bolivar
demanding an end to police abuses and
the implementation of social policies in
the wake of an economic crisis
the protests have been marred by
violence and reported human rights
abuses
with some thinking that about 24 people
have died so far
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
has arrived in ukraine to show support
for the country's response to russian
aggression
mr blinken is going to be talking with
president zielinski during his visit
with the topic of ukraine's desire to
join nato
likely to be discussed ukraine is also
expected to push for all military aid
from the united states amid hostilities
from russian-backed rebels in the
country
the online safety group internet matters
says the level of
harm children face online has increased
dramatically over lockdown
and the most vulnerable children are
most at risk an internet matters report
found a 42 increase in children viewing
content promoting self-harm or suicide
and a 39 rise in sharing
sexual images we saw through the
pandemic the concern by
the government and a number of charities
about the increase in child sexual abuse
um through the pandemic
and certainly you know we want to really
encourage parents to
to just revisit those conversations make
sure they've got the right boundaries
set up with their children
and that they know where they can come
and get some help
police have seized more than 400 knives
and made nearly a thousand arrests in
just
one week of an anti-knife crime
crackdown
forces across england and wales started
this crackdown on monday amid concerns
over rising levels of violence
as lockdown restrictions ease the
metropolitan police say machetes and
rambo
style knives are amongst the blades
taken
now the doctor in charge of nhs
england's response to long
coverage has told sky news that
dedicated clinics to treat the condition
may be needed for much longer than the
current funding allows
the chair of the national long covered
task force says the service which
has already been used by thousands of
people could go on
beyond april next year if the demand is
there
sky news has filmed inside one of the
clinics and spoken to patients who've
suffered with the condition for more
than a year
dan whitehead reports
more than 12 months on and still
recovering
at this long covey clinic in bristol
donna is receiving
physio she has a tight chest and
shortness of breath
my this isn't my voice this is my
covered chest
um so yeah i've got a continuation of
sort of pressure on the chest
and just inflammation really
where would you rate yourself on there
donna contracted kovid19 in march
last year at the start of the pandemic
her gp referred her through
the long covid clinic system but she
says help
wasn't easy to find at first i don't
think the long cover clinic's
particularly visible
would be my first experience with it um
you know sort of myself and a friend did
some research
and then he let me know that he had had
a referral so i chased it up with my gp
who who gave me a referral
so i think particularly there's an issue
with visibility
to improve access 34 million pounds has
now been spent to open
83 clinics across england the first of
which opened
last december nhs england says it
doesn't yet have
solid figures on how many people have
actually used
the long covered clinics we've seen the
numbers of just
five of the 83 which show more than 2
000 people have already been treated
those in charge of the clinics say
demand could mean the service will be
needed well beyond
current funding so we recognize that you
know this is a condition that
the symptoms can be quite prolonged and
we've already seen that from the
patients who
got long covered now about a year ago
some people are still suffering
so there is that sort of time frame to
bear in mind so that is why
additional money has gone in to keep the
clinics going for the course of the next
year
we suspect it may need to go on for much
longer than that
we now have a clinic called the long
cover clinic
north somerset another referral louise's
coveted symptoms have lasted more than a
year
fatigue really is the main thing now um
i've got two children a one-year-old
a sorry two-year-old and a four-year-old
and
it's just very very difficult to get
through
the whole day i've had to accept it
um but yeah it's been it was
a shock to the system and what i need
you to do is walk on the spots
for 40 steps okay ready steady go
new coveted infections are falling
dramatically
left behind are the so-called long
haulers
thousands who may need treatment long
after this pandemic has ended
dan whitehead sky news in bristol
our think tank is calling for urgent
reform to the social care sector amid
their reports claim of a deep
decline in adult welfare welfare the
king's fund analysis of nhs figures
reveals about 120
000 more people requested social care
from councils between
2015 to 2016 with 14 000 fewer people
actually getting help
their report highlighted more funding
and wider availability of help as ways
to improve the sector
the number of people signing up for open
university online courses has surged
during the pandemic the ou says student
numbers have gone up 15
this year with coronavirus being the
main reason as people have looked to
upskill and retrain online with the rise
of distanced learning
the royal mail has revealed images of a
set of 12 special stamps being issued to
celebrate sir paul mccartney it features
a selection of eight records which have
defined
his career from his first solo album in
1970
through to his most recent which was
recorded and released
during lockdown
now let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today how are we looking
today naz
pretty much like yesterday it's another
cool one today and there are going to be
showery conditions also some rain
and hill snow you know typical may
conditions
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning cool and showery conditions
once again for today
and for tomorrow and then as we head
into the weekend
it does look to become milder but it is
also going to be quite wet and windy
much like bank holiday monday
this morning it's a fine start lots of
sunshine frosty though there are some
showers scattered across parts of
england wells patchy rain to the
southwest
rain and hill snow across parts of
scotland even some
snow down towards low levels that rain
and hill snow will become more showers
it spreads southwards through today to
parts of northern england
there may be some heavy downpours with
the risk of hail and thunder
sunshine and showers for ireland
northern ireland england and wales and
patchy rain
moving eastwards along southern coastal
counties of england and it's going to be
another disappointingly
cool day now facebook's oversight board
has upheld the platform's decision to
ban
donald trump on the site it follows the
company's conclusion earlier this year
that mr trump's post incited violence
at the capitol riots the former
president has branded the decision
a total disgrace well let's talk to the
co-chief
executive of free press jessica j
gonzalez
who joins us now good to see you this
morning look
what you make of this banner the way
it's been enforced
listen i think it was the right decision
for facebook to take donald trump off
the platform
in fact i think they took this action
way too late
donald trump was a serial spreader
of hate lies and violence over facebook
and
other social media platforms he
regularly violated
facebook's community guidelines he was
given a pass
time and again because he was the
president of the united states
and finally on january 7th he was
temporarily suspended from facebook
the oversight board yesterday upheld
that suspension
but kicked the ultimate decision about
whether the ban
should be permanent back to facebook
itself
i wish they would have just taken them
down once and for all
now's the time but here we are
so where does that leave um your sort of
analysis of the responsibilities that
facebook
needs to take on board here
well listen the oversight board said
that facebook had shirked its
responsibility
when it refused to just ban trump itself
kicking it over to this board with a set
of
fairly illusory powers um
so you know i believe that facebook
shouldn't have
platformed trump long long ago it's made
exception after exception
and we know that powerful leaders like
donald trump
bolsonaro modi have used facebook um
to exploit and abuse their citizenry
it's important that facebook takes a
stand here
uh and ensures that world leaders cannot
use its platform
um for authoritarianism and
um to to um
abuse their citizens but it's it is a
difficult situation when you talk about
a democratically elected
leader being silenced uh
by a private company in effect i mean
this this is where the lines merge
somewhat don't they
listen this isn't a government right
this isn't a government trying down to
shut down speech of its people this is a
private company
that has decided by that a set of rules
are are are the rules of the road for
their company and that they need
um to hold to account even powerful
leaders
so donald trump still has freedom of
speech
he started his own website this week
he's
you know put out a statement that has
gotten a ton of press attention he
is welcome to start his own website
welcome to start his own
social media platform but he does not
have
the power to have reach on a platform
that he uses for violence for abuse to
spread racism to spread lies about the
pandemic and the vaccine
and so forth he doesn't have that right
that's a privilege
and he hasn't played by the rules and it
was the right decision to take him down
he's got obviously he's from the desk of
donald j
trump up and running now it's
effectively a blog isn't it but i mean
he's still getting his thoughts and
views out there from reading it last
night
still as as pointed as ever
that's right that's right again he's a
powerful person
with a huge following he's free to have
his own
thoughts out there in the world but he
there's no
uh nothing that requires facebook
to carry his content the harm here
is something i think we really need to
talk about
the harm to people who are the subject
of
donald trump's attacks you know here in
the united states
uh donald trump ran thousands of ads
attacking the immigrant
community attacking mexicans and brown
people
we see a mass shooter show up in el paso
texas with a specific
intent to kill mexicans and immigrants
invoking the same language that donald
trump invoked
we saw donald trump spread lies about
the pandemic call the pandemic a hoax
downplay its effects and that really has
an
impact on how people think and behave
and our response to a public health
crisis like this
of course we saw him spread election
lies
and and stir people up to
attack the capital of the united states
um with an insurrection so this is a
real threat
to democracy this is a real threat to
the health and safety
of people around the world and so we
have to really take
it seriously yep we are out of time i'm
sorry to say jessica good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thanks for having me now the deputy
chair of bafta has spoken for the first
time about the allegations against award
winner noel clark
the actor and producer was recognized
just a few weeks ago despite bafta
receiving anonymous complaints of
abusive behavior
and a letter from producers expressing
concern
here's what we know about the decision
to honour noel clark
last month and at the end of march the
academy announced that
he would be this year's winner of the
outstanding british contribution to
cinema
but in the days that followed bafta
received anonymous allegations about his
conduct
followed by a letter from three industry
figures who raised
third-party allegations against clarke
as well as anonymous emails with further
information
but on the 11th of april bafta proceeded
with honoring the actor on the basis
that no women had come forward to them
with a first-hand account of allegations
two and a half weeks later the guardian
published allegations from 20 women
against noel clarke and bafta responded
by suspending the award
and his membership until further notice
lucy cotto reports
[Applause]
receiving a lifetime achievement award
from the british urban film festival in
2019
just hours after the guardian last week
published allegations of abuse against
the actor
he was stripped of the accolade by its
founder
our association with noel started and
ended when we gave the honorary award so
when when i was aware of the
article in the guardian um
i was in complete shock emmanuel anyama
sigue whose festival was partnered with
bafta
has now severed all ties with the
organisation for honoring clark with an
award despite having received anonymous
and third-hand allegations against him
and is calling for the chair kris nenju
majumdar to resign
chris cannot continue in his post
because him being there him remaining
there just sends
completely the wrong signal because
whichever way you look at it bathroom
just dealt with this
horrendously and he has done arguably
some
very good work around diversity he has
um been instrumental in turning it
around in
many ways for nothing it cuts from
nothing i feel
completely let down they also say that
they received no first-hand accounts
and had the victims gone on the record
to them as they did with the guardian
they would have suspended knowles
award immediately they wanted first-hand
accounts they say
but the problem i have with that is not
only are you not meriting the
allegations
when they first came to you directly
through anonymous emails
you're now not meriting this letter that
has come from people that you have
worked with or dealt with
previously at bafta so what are they to
make of your
kind of reaction to them for the first
time
since news about clark and bafta broke
bafta has given an interview to clarify
the timeline of events
and defend its decision to proceed with
the award
if we had had one fraction
of the information that the guardian had
we would never have given an award
to noel clark that is that is obvious
but we didn't have that information
the first time we saw the actual
allegations against him was when they
were published by the guardian newspaper
and as soon as we saw the allegations we
suspended the award
there will be a lot of people listening
to this who will say
you had heard allegations
even if they weren't first-hand you were
certainly aware that allegations were
being made against him
we were aware that people had spoken out
against noel and had made assertions
that he had not behaved correctly
but they were very generalized and they
were in the main
totally anonymous we were never in the
position of having a first-hand
testimony from anyone
about what he had done or when he'd done
it we've been speaking to the head
of the british urban film festival who
has called for the chair of after
chris magenda to stand down to resign
saying that the buck starts and stops
with him
um what's your response to that krish
has
worked uh all the way through um
together with the board it has been a um
a joint uh decision-making process it is
really uh i think not right to single
people out
you stand by both krish and amanda berry
to stay in their positions
absolutely yeah whatever the
ramifications for bafta itself
what is indisputable is that women were
too frightened to come forward sooner
leaving huge questions for the industry
as a whole
lucy cossa sky news
london science museum has come under
criticism after it was revealed that the
sponsor for their new climate exhibition
is the oil giant shell environmental
activists say they'll call for the
exhibition to be boycotted
if the company isn't dropped as a major
sponsor
our climate correspondent lisa hollands
reports
london's science museum is preparing to
reopen after lockdown
with the uk's first exhibition on
capturing carbon
the main attraction is a future climate
solution
a full-scale mechanical tree brought
over from america
it replicates how trees naturally soak
up
carbon dioxide it's widely accepted that
technology to capture carbon
and store it will be needed for the uk
to get to net zero by
2050 but amongst some contributors
like the climate scientist involved in
this display on capturing carbon in
woodlands
the excitement of taking part has been
overshadowed
by learning the exhibition is being
sponsored by the oil company
shell this sponsorship issue has created
a big conundrum for me because on the
one hand
i want to support the exhibition and the
the key messages
of the exhibition but then on the other
hand i don't want to be associated with
sponsorship by big oil companies
the museum has defended its choice of
sponsors
actually we keep complete editorial
control of our exhibitions
no matter the sponsor so um
they're actually not no sponsor is ever
involved in the exhibition per se
but it's awkward isn't it if exhibitors
want to distance themselves
because of the sponsor that you have
as i say you know we we do have complete
editorial control
but that hasn't satisfied climate
activists who say they'll call for a
boycott of the exhibition
if shell isn't dropped for decades the
climate movement have been
um trying to bring about
action on climate justice on the climate
crisis and also educate the public
and the fact that the science museum is
accepting the sponsorship is really
undermining the work
that we've been doing shell says its
target is to become a net zero emissions
energy business by 2050
and it has a long-standing relationship
with the science museum
which is planning to open the exhibition
in two weeks time
lisa holland sky news central london
and just to remind you you can see the
daily climate show every weekday at half
six and a half nine here on sky news
still to come for you this morning
children's author
michael rosen shares his experiences of
suffering
with long covert
[Music]
i'm starting a 10 000 kilometer cycle
around the uk which i'm hoping to
complete in 80 days
um going from london the whole way to
our tokyo which we're calling stokio
now that things are opening up and we
can get out you know being outside in
the great outdoors is really good for
your mental health and your
just your health in general and
hopefully my little journey people can
come and
visit me i've got a website tracking me
and the whole
peanut butter website you can go there
find out where i am if you want to come
and join me
come and join me if you want me to come
and camp in your garden or you have a
field i'd love to come along and maybe
we can do some
outdoor activities together i'm going to
be eating a lot of peanut butter i might
mix it up with some other kind of
regional foods around the uk
i don't know maybe a bakewell tart with
a slathering of peanut butter over the
top might be delicious so i'm going to
play around with it but
i have a little pouch here which have my
jar of peanut butter
so hopefully that'll naturally fuel me
the whole way to stokyo
[Music]
the curious and the ones who want to be
entertained backstage sky news's
entertaining podcast
but wherever you are welcome to safety
rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky story
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
rain and hill snow will spread
southwards across scotland today and
then to northern england later with a
risk of hail and thunder too
meanwhile some rain may affect southern
coastal counties of england
elsewhere we'll see scattered showers in
between sunny spells
and again it'll be a cool day everywhere
currently tree pollen is airborne such
as birch
and oak as well as plain pollen in some
cities there will be moderate levels of
these
for today low across northern parts of
scotland and spore would temporarily
increase
after any rain the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now i've been talking this morning about
long coved which is
all a bit of a mystery people seem to
have different symptoms and
no one can quite get to the bottom of it
one person who
is really suffering is children's author
michael rosen who can join us now it's
good to see you
this morning and i know you you actually
had a really rough time with covert
didn't you actually in the
in the initial stages
yes that's right i was in intensive care
for a 47 48 days i was in a coma for
about 40 of those um so it hit me really
badly yes
and so coming out of that now when
hopefully people think well maybe you
you'd find some sense of recovery again
this long
covert issue has really affected you
what sort of symptoms are you showing
with that
well because i got micro bleeds in my
brain it knocked out
my left eye and left ear
um and it seems as if the covid
virus can attack what are called the
peripheral nervous system the edges of
ourselves if you like
so i've got numb toes and i get
dizziness
quite often the blood clots which are
also caused by covid have cleared up it
seems in my brain
and in my lungs and then there's a
general fatigue because
it's thought that the virus now one of
the thoughts every cell has got a little
thing that they call the powerhouse of
the cell the mitochondrion
and they think it probably somehow
rather attacks that that's the little
bit in your cell
that turns the food into energy so that
seems to be one of the reasons why
there's so many symptoms
so where has this left you in terms of
of
trying to get on with life
well i've adapting to the fact that i
can
hardly see so i can't really see you
looking at my screen there
um this year i have a hearing aid which
sort of gives me a bit of 3d
sound but it's it's quite strange it
sounds as if i'm always listening to the
radio
which as it happens i do radio so it's
kind of rather odd
it sounds as if i'm on the radio to
myself all the time
and the the num toes are more of an
irritant than
a sort of you know a disability or
anything like that but it is kind of
annoying
um particularly if i'm walking around in
slippers and so on
because it just it it sort of bothers me
but it's the dizziness that
surprises me because sometimes
my wife emma she sort of notices i kind
of stagger against the wall or suddenly
grab the table so that's a bit worrying
if i'm out
what what has happened in terms of i
mean in getting a diagnosis for this and
the potential for any sort of treatment
because
i mean with all this we know people are
presenting different
perhaps similar but still different uh
uh responses to lancovid i mean
it does seem that getting any sort of of
actual treatment
is is extremely difficult well i think
we're coming into the category of
what people call post-viral syndrome so
that it's known that viruses of various
kinds
can have two four five ten twenty years
effect people talk about
me obviously and it's it's not imaginary
so
you know people are saying well some of
it we just have to live with people
who are suffering severe severe fatigue
also other people are suffering
what they're calling brain fog i think i
did get that in the first months after i
came out of intensive care
i was getting memory loss and and
getting muddled and fuzzy if there was
as it were too much information
coming at me uh there are now some long
covered clinics
um i suspect there are some people well
i belong to a long-coved
group on facebook uh other social medias
are available
um that um we join and we share some of
these and i can see some people
in severe difficulty about literally
getting up some days they can
some days they can't i call it alternate
day syndrome i sort of if i over
exercise one day and i do try to
exercise a bit every day
then i kind of i get a kind of bout of
of being able to do virtually nothing
for a few hours the next day
what is your message then i mean
obviously some people are
are trying to get treatment and there is
talk now that these long covered clinics
are going to have to be around for a lot
longer than
what was initially planned and but is
there a sense i mean with the facebook
groups and all the rest of it
is there a sense that just being able to
connect with people who are
suffering in a similar way does does
that help is there a sense of community
and mutual support there
there is i mean when i put up the fact
that i was getting these bouts of
dizziness
up came another whole set of posts of
people saying oh me too
me too and then again i posted up some
of the latest stuff that seems to be
pointing at the the mitochondrion that
somehow the virus is getting into the
mitochondria
um and again the huge great wave of post
some people are putting up what they
find useful
you know vitamins or other things and
the moment that people are experimenting
with that
and the attitude to exercise is little
and often rather
than trying to do kind of great big
bouts of exercise for
you know a couple of hours one day and
doing nothing for a few days
but doing little and often and i find
that a useful recommendation
but where there are things like severe
skin rashes and so on i get
mild skin rash um
then you know the gp and some medication
is
is necessary but the fatigue you know
there's not much you can do about it but
it's actually people younger than me who
are trying to get into
work five days a week i mean some of
it's being if you like disguised because
of
um lockdowns and so on and people
working from home
but there are a lot of people out there
who couldn't
if there was full ordinary working
conditions wouldn't be able to work for
five days a week it's just you know
40 hours it's too much well look we
really appreciate you
sharing your experiences with us michael
good to see you as always thank you
thank you stephen thanks very much okay
let's get a quick check on the weather
for you now here's nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's uh cool and showery
once again for today
and for tomorrow as well then as we head
into the weekend
it's going to turn milder but it's also
going to be wet
and windy before that so this morning
it's chilly frosty for many areas but
there's plenty of sunshine to greet many
areas this morning it's a cloudier
affair though across parts of central
northern scotland some rain until snow
there maybe some snow
you see lying on the ground across parts
of scotland first thing
moving down towards southern scotland
later and to northern england most of it
light and patchy but some heavy
downpours some hail still possible
some hill snow as well meanwhile for
ireland northern ireland england and
wales it's a case of sunshine and
showers today there's also an area of
patchy rain currently across parts of
the southwest
that will be moving its way eastwards
along southern coastal counties of
england
another disappointingly cool day as well